the Israeli military has carried out a
series of airstrikes on the Gaza Strip
at least 12 people have been killed
three of them leaders in alcud's
brigades the military wing of the
Islamic Jihad twenty other people were
also wounded Israel says it's been
targeting sites belonging to the group
let's get more on our story we go live
to Gaza and speak to yumina El Saeed
good to see you yumna what more do we
know about the three leaders that were
targeted and killed and any civilians
also killed in those strikes
yes meleen so as you mentioned the three
commanders in alcott's brigades the
military wing of Islamic Jihad have been
assassinated by Israeli uh drones uh the
Israeli military also announced that 40
were jets and drones carried out the
operation and assassinating these
leaders and the airstrikes following
them now the death toll is 12 at least
12 people by the Ministry of Health and
20 others at least injured now from from
these 12 three of them are the Islamic
Jihad commanders while the nine others
are civilians in uh
mostly families of these commanders and
also civilians around the apartments
that were targeted while the 20 are also
civilians and residents now the
targeting happened to two residents
social apartments in residential
buildings one of them is right there as
uh if the camera can pan over it's right
there in the middle of Gaza City while
the other uh apartment was in Rafa the
southern part of the Gaza Strip a lot of
Destruction has been caused to that
residential building and of course a lot
of injuries happened from that targeting
now the Israeli Army has called this
military operation that it has carried
against the Gaza Strip as the protective
arrow and it announced the assassination
or the success of the assassination of
the Islamic Jihad Targets in an official
statement by alcott's brigades the
military wing of Islamic Jihad they
mourned their Martyrs the great
mujahideen leaders Jihad al-ranim Khalil
albertani and
also mourned their families their wives
and children who were killed in the
assassination attacks Maline also Hamas
has mourned in its statement the
commanders killed in Islamic Jihad and
the political leader of Hamas Ismail
said in a statement that the occupation
miscalculated and will pay the price for
its crime and that the resistance alone
will determine the way that hurts the
occupation he also said that this
aggression targets the entire
Palestinian people and the resistance is
Unified in confronting it
so also uh Malene I I have to say that
Palestinian factions have announced that
uh they are in a high state of alert and
mobilization in different areas across
the Gaza Strip
right yumna as you say uh we the Islamic
Jihad and Hamas both denouncing these
strikes I wonder do you get a sense this
could be the beginning of further
escalation
well yes of course meleen we're still
waiting these hours now it's been almost
an hour where no strikes no Israeli
strikes have been taking place as Israel
right after the assassination announced
the beginning of Israeli strikes along
the Gaza Strip now we're waiting to see
the Palestinian factions response for uh
for the assassination and for these
strikes now uh from all the statements
of different factions the Palestinian
factions they seem to be unified uh
Ismail hania's statement shows that
there is going to be a unification in
the response to the Israeli
assassination of the Islamic Jihad
commanders so uh the the coming areas
are very crucial we still don't know
when the Palestinian response is going
to be but according to this Palestine
universe response this is going to
determine how complicated and how
further the escalation will take if it's
going to end up in a matter of day or
two or will take us to a larger and more
complicated escalation than that okay
for now good to speak to you now Saeed
with that update from Gaza